1998 I email wine libraries database and  say today we are offering free shipping  on winelibrary.com  we were a four million dollar business  it is still today the biggest day in  sales in Wine Library history even  though we are a 60 million dollar  business  people lost their mind  people bought wine that day as if it had  the Cure inside  because they'd never seen free shipping  before one guy left a note saying I'm  buying this wine for my daughter's  wedding thank you so much me living in  the thank you economy  12 years ago not realizing I was living  in it decided to email the gentleman say  thank you so much congratulations you  know when's the date  he says no no Gary my daughter's 12 but  this is a great deal  [Applause]  I mean how ridiculous is that  he literally bought 12 cases of wine  15 years before he needed it because of  free shipping